ensuite dans cette même vidéo on voit
personne qui s'approche d'eux qui
s'approche mais qui dit mais c'est pas
comme ça qu'il faut faire
et ce n'est pas respectée règlement
parce qu'en général dans les règlements
de l'association il ya marqué tir
fichant obligatoires
or les prix normalement le président est
responsable de tout ce qui se passe dans
l'association est c'est un article de
loi je me rappelais plus de 168 quelque
chose il a pour ce faire des gardes
particuliers
attaché
l'association qui doit faire respecter
la loi sur territoire de chasse et là il
ya personne qui ce qui était présenté
donc il ya là c'est on voit pointer un
problème de police de la chasse alors si
je peux faire deux propositions
c'est d'abord au niveau du permis de
chasser sachant qu'en france la
formation au permis de chasser c'est une
journée
et quand on passe le permis on passe un
quart d'heure dans une salle avec des
avec des vidéos et on passe demi heure
sur un parcours en tirant sur des cibles
mouvantes mes sens en efficacité on
tient pas que du content du résultat
et on a son permis de chasser alors nous
enfin moi parce que nous estimons que
c'est absolument insuffisant et nous
conseillons de s'inspirer du permis
allemand
et et en plus c'est des crs et les
chasseurs qui propose qui propose les
les règles de sécurité or elles seront
proposées par département dont quatre
sont pas absolument égal en france ce
qui est contraire aussi à la loi est ce
que nous proposons nous c'est que ce
soit serré de sécurité soient édictées
par les ministères
y revenir au gré des questions à
monsieur parce que dire alors les bazars
voudrais pas vous ai parlé de labatut de
notre déplacement sur les se sait
parfaitement sans intérêt excusez moi
par rapport à ce que vous avez
ce qui nous intéresse c'est que vous ne
fassiez des propositions
nous faire une remarque et des critiques
de choses qui se sont passées gère bien
que la pratique la rubrique les
chasseurs oui mais c'est un exemple cinq
équipes à être généralisée donc
effectivement peut-être que
je ne crois pas mais en tout cas donc
vous avez compris on est nombreux cet
après midi ce qu'on veut c'est que tout
le monde puisse s'exprimer donc
l'intérêt c'est que vous puissiez faire
des propositions concrètes et que si
nous dire effectivement les points qui
selon vous mérite d'être
évoquée et d'être partagée voilà pour
donc qu' on puisse travailler dans de
bonnes conditions
bonjour
je donne je représente le rac qui était
également invitée et je parle également
au nom de la hausse et puisque les deux
travaillent ensemble maintenant donc je
vais venir sur les points très pratique
puisqu'on est sur la sécurisation de la
chasse et pas sur un débat sur la chasse
les trois quarts des accidents dont sont
essentiellement lieu dans des bêtes dans
des chasses de grand gibier
je suis ranger également parmi toutes
les formations ou très tôt loeb de
terrain dont je travaille notamment dans
des zones difficiles dans des parcs
nationaux en rdc etc et parmi les reins
que je travaille ce sont tous des gens
qui sont très spécialisé dans les armes
qui sont qui teste les armes pour
l'armée qui sont également puisqu'on
pourra dans des endroits où on forme les
rangers donc qui sont des spécialistes
du tir
du tir de précision et qui forme
également les instructeurs des forces
spéciales dont je pense qu'ils sont
parfaitement à même de répondre à ça il
protège la faune sauvage et donc on a
des règles quand on travaille en tant
que ranger qui devrait s'appliquer à
priori à toute personne munie d'une arme
dans la nature et qui cas phase de la
chasse ou autre hormis ces quatre
principes à laquelle auquel tout ranger
et donc tout chasseur puisque la plupart
sont détenteurs d'un permis de chasse
doivent se former et rappelons que les
trois pères des accidents ne proviennent
pas d'une problème d'une arme qu'elle
soit longue portée ou pas l'emporter ne
proviennent pas d'une munition ne
proviennent pas d'une distance ac une
zone d'habitation au contraire nous
sommes contre le fait de ce qui
apparaîtrait à frire et comme une bonne
situation d'augmenter la distance entre
les habitations et la chasse ce qui est
impossible matériellement mais ce qui en
fait on augmente le risque d'accident
puisque les gens ne le verront pas les
habitations même si un chasseur comment
ranger comme toute personne comme ça est
censé dans les quatre règles de base
connaître son environnement
on appelle ça connaître les conditions
connaître les conditions est ce si ces
quatre règle devra s'appliquer à tous
chasseurs est donc permis de chasse
c'est connaître son environnement veut
dire connaître les conditions
environnementales connaître où il y à
des habitations où il ya des routes
connaître ce qui se cache derrière les
buissons mais également connaître l'état
de son arme connaître le fonctionnement
de son d'armes connaître ses cadres ses
propres capacités pour la connaître des
différentes choses comme ça il ya
également le fait
deux effectives en de savoir se
transporter avec une âme de ne pas
laisser son doigt sur la détente de se
promener avec une arme qui n'est pas
chargé et qui n'est pas en situation de
danger parce qu'effectivement votre arme
la queue de détente se prend dans le jt
de votre veste le kopa voilà il ya
différentes choses comme ça donc pas
remis étant donné que ce n'est pas en
lui même des erreurs de manipulation
est ce que c'est une question d'âge que
c'est une question qui a été posée de
toutes les enquêtes que j'ai menée sur
une dizaine de personnes spécialistes ce
n'est jamais une question d'âge c'est
une question de pratique et
d'inexpérience ou deux sur expérience
c'est à dire line expérimentation ou le
fait de ne pas être habitué à une arme
provoque effectivement des accidents
mais le fait d'être effectivement de se
croire très expérimenté est également
induit un excès de confiance c'est comme
ça qu'on a beaucoup de problèmes et
d'anciens avec 2,2 des chasseurs plus
âgés c'est pas en termes d'âge en terme
d'expérience vous pouvez répéter pas son
permis de son permis à 40 ans pas une
question d'âge mais
voilà donc c'est une première un
problème d'expérience donc pour nous
comme monsieur fillon l'expliqué le
permis en france n'a permis qui se joue
sur 24 heures dans tous les autres pays
puisque donc moi les gens et que je
travaille travaille dans le monde entier
que ce soit en italie que ce soit en
allemagne les formations vont de un mois
à trois mois ce sont des formations
théoriques et pratiques qui sont
dispensés par des professionnels qui
vous implique de bien connaître au
niveau la biologie l'environnement le
comportement savoir reconnaître les
espèces menacées savoir reconnaître les
sexes connaître les comportements de
quoi ils se nourrissent etc mais
également comprendre les comportements
des animaux pour ne pas induire des
comportements dangereux et notamment
dans le
dans l'est qui ont des fonctionnements
indépendant
donc dans tous ces cas tigirlas ils ont
également une formation pratique qui
impose donc dans le maniement des armes
de connaître le maniement des andes qui
n'est pas le cas en france un quart
d'heure de manipulation des armes dans
cette même journée ce sont des gens qui
ne savent pas tirer qui ne connaissent
pas le maniement de leurs armes ce qui
est extrêmement dangereux donc
effectivement on impose partout là bas
vous avez line se distinguer en italie
en allemagne c'est la même chose donc
vous avez effectivement ceux ci qui vous
impose notamment dans l'examen avec des
cibles mouvantes vous devez réussir 75%
des tirs dans une zone une cible qui est
au niveau du coeur et autour du coeur
une zone létale si vous n'avez pas 75%
sur les cibles mouvantes qui sont
atteintes vous n'avez pas votre permis
donc voilà ce sont des choses comme ça
qui sont importants vous avez également
le permis en italie qui est qui doit se
renouveler tous les cinq ans en
allemagne tous les trois ans et visite
médicale pour les 10 ans nous nous
proposons sur la même sur la même mesure
que le tir sportif vous devez fournir un
certificat médical tous les ans pour
nous il paraît impératif quintilla qu'un
examen médical soit imposé tous les ans
avec contrôler effectivement évaluation
psychologique et évaluation de vos
capacités physiques voilà est-ce que
vous avez toujours une bonne vue est-ce
que vous avez des troubles locomoteurs
est-ce que voilà votre médecin traitant
le sait mais également dans tous ces
pays là contrairement à la france en
belgique en italie en allemagne l'alcool
est interdit
si vous donnez un exemple en terme de
législation vous êtes vous n'êtes pas en
situation de chasse vous êtes en train
de rentrer chez vous il ya quelqu'un
d'autre qui est au volant vous êtes à
côté vous êtes saoul
si vous êtes sous vous perdez et que
vous avez un permis de chasse un permis
de port d'armes vous perdez les deux
voilà donc nous demandons ça et nous
demandons également comme ce sont les
armes qui peuvent être mis en cause
mise en cause nous demandons également
un principe de contrôle technique des
armes sur le même principe que le
contrôle automobile qui doit être fait
qu'il devrait être faire chaque année et
en rappelle effectivement
également des compétences un contrôle de
ces équipements des compétences des
personnes et nous demandons également
que
la personne qui gère l'oeuvre qui
organise la chasse doit être tenu
responsable au même titre que le
chassant responsables ont un problème de
police de chasse dans ce cas là si elles
ont pour les mêmes sanctions retrait de
permis de chasse en cas de première
infraction et permettez je voudrais
vraiment qu'on reste surtout ce timing
vous aurez le temps de revenir très
franchement c'est très intéressant ce
que vous dites et je vous remercie de
votre exposé que kiki est tout à fait
passionnant l'intérêt c'est vraiment que
confie que vos spécialités un petit peu
pour qu'on puisse bien vous identifier
pour revenir vous poser des questions
mais vous inquiétez pas
on reviendra à vous poser des questions
bonjour donc moi je suis valérie dumaine
et je représente la spa ce associations
de protection des animaux sauvages donc
c'est une association qui est nié il ya
40 ans suite à un accident de chasse en
fait où le couple deux fondateurs a pu
voir une balle traversée dans son salon
donc clairement nous on va travailler
vraiment la question de l'insécurité à
la chasse et de la cohabitation
notamment entre les usagers de la nature
on est vraiment ravis de pouvoir être
auditionné dans ce cadre là donc on va
aller aussi très rapidement sur les sur
les sujets et les propositions on a
faut savoir que je nous on travaille on
est un peu un révélateur aussi de la
société civile on a récolté depuis des
années nombre de témoignages les
accidents de chasse ont connu il ya des
chiffres de l'om mais on ne peut pas les
remettre en question ce qui est
néanmoins beaucoup moins connu c'est les
incidents et le sentiment en fait que
provoque lusage de la nature que ce soit
du coup par tous ses usagers
donc on va vous remettre en fin de
séance on a ça fait deux ans notamment
qu'on récolte des témoignages qui
permettent de révéler cette insécurité
on vous remet aussi les témoignages pour
récolter un jour un chasseur qui voilà
qui sont des témoignages qui permettent
de montrer ce que laisse que les usagers
non chasseurs du coup donc les preneurs
les vététistes les randonneurs peuvent
ressentir quand il se promène
aujourd'hui tous les jours ils peuvent
te prenais puisqu'il n'y a pas
d'interdiction de ce prix
les témoignages sont aussi révélés par
les sondages notamment il ya un sondage
ipsos montré par bost qui révèle que
quand même 76 % des habitants en zone
rurale ont déjà renoncé à se promener
donc c'est là on parle vraiment encore
une fois de l'usaj de la nature et c'est
vrai que nous on revoit dans les
témoignages en fait c'était peur
incessante donc soin des personnes
portant une arme soit des chiens aussi
qu'ils sont associés et je me permets
quand même révélé que l'audition de
willy schraen
il a quand même mis en avant que les
chasseurs avait posté des faux
témoignages auprès des associations qui
a récolté ces témoignages donc donc à la
fois nous on tient à votre disposition
les coordonnées pour montrer voilà la
véracité des gens qui témoignent qui
notamment veulent témoigner souvent de
manière anonyme parce qu'ils ont peur et
voilà on ne peut que dénoncer quand même
une attitude un peu délétère de ses
usagers de la turquie vont enfin qui va
être un peu contre-productif
ça c'est le côté un peu généralisés mais
vous vous plongerez je l'espère dans ces
témoignages
une des demandes qu'on a c'est qui est
porté par beaucoup d'associations c'est
de limiter les jours de chasse donc on
va vous proposer de limiter deux jours
de la semaine un jour de week-end et un
jour de la semaine
il faut réfléchir bien sûr aux jours les
plus probants on sait que les accidents
et les incidents ont lieu à 43% le
dimanche et à 30% le samedi forcément
c'est là où il ya le plus d'usagers le
samedi c'est aussi un jour traditionnel
de battues mais voilà ça montre que si
on veut un partage de la nature et un
changement de paradigme aussi surtaxés
la
cette étude d incident révèle que bon a
priori
le samedi ou le dimanche en tout cas ce
serait un jour de meilleur partage je
vous disais aussi enfin voilà les 76 %
d'habitants qui ont peur de sortir ou
qui ne sortent plus et on sait aussi ça
c'est un sondage ifop mais qui a été
révélé que 70 % presque des français
seraient favorables à l'interdiction de
la chasse ce week-end et pendant les
vacances scolaires c'est assez rare qui
est autant d'humanité dans des sondages
donc on voit bien que 40 ans après la
naissance de la spa ce qui est née sur
ces incidents là on retrouve aujourd'hui
le ces besoins qui finalement sont
toujours aussi présents et on a bien lu
qu'avec les temps de confinement le
retour à la nature est devenu quelque
chose de très vital et donc il nous
apparaît vraiment important qu
effectivement aujourd'hui se pose la
question de ce partage de la nature et
je vais pas rappeler ce que mes
collègues ont rappelé quand même qu
effectivement dans d'autres pays
européens la chasse est soit interdite
soit limitée
et notamment on voit qu'en angleterre la
chasse est interdite le dimanche c'est
qu'en allemagne elle est même carrément
interdite l'ensemble des jours de la
semaine et je laisse ma collègue on
prend le reste du temps pour expliquer
d'autres oui merci question noire je
vous prends secondes
mais marianne en gros nos amis oui non
mais on comprend donc on prend ça avec
eux
qui portent tous oublié quand même
réalité qu'eux en plus des témoignages
on a quand même une expérience nourrie
par ce qu'on appelle les refuges à se
passer c'est à dire c'est des espaces
sur lesquels on aide les propriétaires
interdire l'achat dans leur démarche qui
n'est pas toujours facile et on les aide
à faire respecter cette interdiction
aujourd'hui on à 1300 refuge à ce
passent en france qui représente douze
mille hectares dans ce cas le cadre de
ces de ses refuges en a quotidiennement
en période de chasse des des témoignages
de personnes qui subissent des balles
qui retombent sur les toits des coups de
feu à proximité de chez elle des chiens
de chasse se lancer sur les terrains des
insultes des menaces donc donc on est
vraiment prêt de ce qui se passe sur le
terrain
et on a malheureusement souvent aussi
une attitude des chasseurs responsable
qui ajoute à cette souffrance puisque il
n'y a aucune excuse qui est qui est fait
quand tu es quand des incidents des
incidents surviennent
il ya certaines personnes qui souhaitent
développer des activités économiques qui
ne peuvent pas souhaité à la pression de
chasse et dans ce cadre de ces refuges
aussi nous déposons des plaintes une
fois côté des associations mais on a
conscience de la difficulté pour qu'une
plainte aboutisse dans ce domaine donc
en dix ans on a simplement on a déposé
seulement une trentaine de plaintes est
sûre cette trentaine d'apprentis n'y a
que deux plaintes qui ont abouti à une
condamnation parce qu'il ya toujours des
problèmes de preuves des grosses
difficultés de preuves de l'acte de
chasse et d'identification des auteurs
des actes illégaux et donc en l'absence
de preuves c'est la parole des uns
contre la parole des autres voilà
souvent des plaintes classées sans suite
et au niveau des mesures pour remédier à
cela on a plusieurs propositions donc on
va pas développer ici mais ce serait
notamment le fait d' inverser le
aujourd'hui pour interdire la chasse
chez soi un propriétaire doit faire doit
organiser une démarche l'idée ce serait
d'inverser ce principe là et dire que
par principe les terrains pacha sable
un style faudrait rajouter alors on peut
discuter voir cette mesure d'ajouter un
rayon autour des habitations pour sur
lesquels dans lequel la chasse serait
interdite et aussi ça nous tient peu à
coeur aussi d'interdire clairement la
chasse dans le cadre des enclos
d'animaux domestiques parce que c'est
souvent le cas et on rejoint également
j'étais déjà très généreux je suis
désolé il ya aussi mais à préciser quand
même que aussi tout ce qui est la
responsabilité pénale
des chasseurs on estime qu'il faudrait
vraiment une une la création
d'infraction à l'image de ce cas pour
les automobilistes et des propriétaires
de chiens pour
la responsabilité qu'on a quand on est
d'accord on est avec des armes dans la
nature fabien
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je vous remercie de nous
recevoir aujourd'hui pour travailler
ensemble à une meilleure sécurisation de
la chasse je suis là de barberis ou
d'intérêt général de l'association
stéphane lamart et doctorante en droit
français et européen de l'environnement
je suis accompagné de patrice grillon
avocat conseiller à l'association alors
il ya beaucoup de sujets qu'on aimerait
abordé j'espère qu'on y reviendra
effectivement autour des tables rondes
je vais max est sur un sujet qui me
tient à coeur et qui est peu évoquée
dans le la question de la sécurisation
de la chasse c'est la question de la
participation active ou passive des
mineurs à la chasse
en fait en france dans les mineures en
l'interdiction d'acheter ou consommer de
l'alcool du tabac de jouer à des jeux
d'argent d'effectuer des travaux
d'abattage d'euthanasie d'équarrissage
de conduire sans être accompagné par
contre en france on a le droit à seize
ans d'aller chasser seul en forêt tout
seul et à 15 ans d'aller chasser en
chasse accompagnée avec un fusil partagé
pour deux avec un chasseur titulaire
d'un permis depuis au moins cinq ans et
on a droit de tirer à 15 ans et ce après
une formation symbolique de deux heures
à une demi-journée qui ne sont non
sanctionné par un examen final donc un
enfant de 15 ans a le droit de tirer
sans avoir passé un examen
est séparé pour le piégeage on va y
revenir là défilement je vais je vous ai
rendu un dossier à ce sujet qui détaille
tout je vais essayer d'être brève par
rapport à la définition juridique de
l'acte de chasse il ya beaucoup de
choses qui ne sont pas définies
légalement comme acte de chasse le fait
de rechercher du gibier d'abattre un
gibier mourant la curée lors de la
chasse à courre le contrôle du résultat
d'un tir sur un animal dont tout ça peut
être fait par un mineur même un mineur
de deux ans et c'est le cas en fait
quand vous regardez les forums de
chasseurs et a énormément de témoignages
je vous en ai mis pas mal sûr sur le
site qui témoigne je vous en ai
quelques-uns très bref ma première
chasse c'était à 3 ans équipé d'une
combinaison de ski monfils a commencé à
trac en cette année j'ai amené mon fils
à l'âge de deux ans le plus chiant c'est
de faire attention tu ne tombe pas j'ai
commencé à l'âge de 5 ans dès l'âge de
12 ans j'avais ma 30 30 donc c'est un
armes une arme de chasse j'ai un truc à
notre cadence de leurs vertus et les
premiers canards dès l'âge de 7 ou 8 ans
j'ai emmené mon fils pour la première
fois à quatre mois et depuis ses trois
ans je ne fais pas une sortie sans lui à
7 ans il a tiré son premier morillon
poser à 8 ans et d'attirer son premier
chipeau je sais pas si vous vous rendez
compte on peut aussi s'étonner qu'à une
option chasse au lycée inde en
collission peut avoir des points avec
l'option cynégétique et les fédérations
de chasse n'hésitent pas à détourner la
législation et réglementation française
afin de partir faire participer au
maximum les mineurs à l'acte de chasse
dominique à stella qui est vice
président de l'union nationale des
associations de piégeur agréé de france
ironisé sur l'arrêté interdisant
l'agrément aux moins de 16 ans en disant
cette nouvelle restriction pourra être
facilement détourné en faisant de ces
jeunes à nos auxiliaires pour revenir
pour relever nos pièges au quotidien et
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez il ya
deux ans et un one voice qui a infiltré
la vénerie sous terre et un enfants de 5
et 12 ans il ya une vidéo sur internet
je vais pas vous l'a diffusé parce que
c'est assez dur on voit un enfant de 5
et 12 ans obligés d'abattre à coups de
pelle des renardeaux qui viennent d'être
des tarés déterré alors que l'enfant de
12 ans n'a pas envie on imagine bien le
traumatisme que c'est dans le droit
européen et international
sachez que beaucoup de pays sont moins
permissif que la france belgique suisse
pays-bas des cantons d'argentine ont
limité la chasse au mieux aux majeurs
libère en italie il faut avoir 18 ans et
être accompagnés pendant un an d'un
titulaire de permis de chasse depuis au
moins 3 ans en pologne la participation
active ou passive des mineurs à la
chasse est interdite quand je dis
participation passive donges entendent
accompagner son enfant à la chasse de
l'amener à la chasse donc la france est
très indulgente or il serait primordial
interdire cette participation à la
chaîne pour des questions de sécurité et
d'intégrité physique et morale les
chasseurs témoigne là aussi je vous ai
mis les témoignages vu que le temps est
compté je vais pas vous les maîtres mais
de la difficulté de surveiller un enfant
en bas âge lorsqu'ils nous accompagna la
chasse les enfants courent si on leur
met des as des casques antibruit ils
n'entendent rien donc on peut pas les
rappeler à l'ordre et on est moins
vigilant donc c'est beaucoup d'accidents
chaque année il y à des mineurs qui sont
victimes d'accidents de chasse qui dès
mineurs qui participent à la chasse qui
sont victimes des mineurs responsables
d'accidents de chasse et des mineurs
témoins d'accidents de chasse je vais à
la chasse avec mon père et je vois un
accident de chasse je vais pas vous
faire la liste exacte exhaustive mais
juste pour vous donner un ordre d'idée
en 2020 un chasseur de 16 ans s'est tué
accidentellement devant son frère de 12
ans je vous parle d'accident lors d'une
partie de chasse 1 en 2019 un enfant de
12 ans accompagnés en proche chasseurs
et blessé un mineur de 16 ans tue
accidentellement un homme de 47 ans un
jeune tu y es tu son frère nom tire sur
son frère et lui arrache son doigt son
frère de 14 ans durant la saison
2017-2018 un chasseur de 17 ans est tué
par son cousin chasseurs de 13 ans un
enfant de 13 ans meurt après avoir reçu
une balle en pleine tête tirée par son
grand père chasseur alors qu'ils
ramassaient un volant un volatile un
enfant de 12 ans est grièvement blessé
lors d'une battue une fille de dix huit
18 ans et plus et au visage par des
coups de fusil tirés par son frère à
l'âge de 14 ans je saute des années mais
il y en a chaque année en 2013 un jeune
de 14 ans se suicide durant une partie
de chasse après avoir tué
accidentellement son père un jeune se
suicide après tué son père lors d'une
partie de chasse un garçon de 6 ans est
tuée par un chasseur de 16 ans alors en
chasse accompagnée et non titulaire du
permis en 2010 un enfant de 12 ans est
tué accidentellement par son frère
chasseurs de 17 ans je vous continuez
pas la suite il y en a chaque année
et parfois aussi il ya beaucoup même
tout le temps il ya des accidents causés
par des armes de chasse qu'ils sont à
domicile donc là en 2021 garçon de 18
mois est grièvement blessée par sa soeur
de quatre ans avec une arme de chasse
qui était au domicile en 2020 un garçon
de 9 ans tue sa soeur de six ans avec
une arme de chasse qui est un domicile
donc c'est fréquent il faut il faut
étudier les chiffres regarder le dossier
voilà il y en a énormément ri c'est de
faire vite et en dehors de ça par
rapport à la sécurité
ok bon
voilà il ya à côté de ça il ya bien sûr
des conséquences néfastes néfaste pour
l'intégrité morale ce que je vous disais
un enfant est traumatisé il ya eu un
colloque à l'assemblée nationale avec le
comité des droits de l'enfant des
nations unies qui relève que les qui
relève des conséquences de l'exposition
des enfants à la violence exercée sur
les animaux perte d' empathie
incivilités croissantes à la souffrance
et à la mort actuellement des violences
il y a eu des tribune signée par des
psychologues et tout ça voilà donc il
apparaît juste une très bonne il
apparaît essentiel interdire la
participation active ou passive des
mineurs à la chasse
bien poursuivre
bonjour à tous et merci d'abord de votre
habitation même la présidente monsieur
le rapporteur donc moi je suis stanislas
broniszewski et je représente ici le
collectif havas pour abolissons la
vénerie aujourd'hui donc ben je suis en
compagnie de l'oea le faucheur qui avec
moi ici aussi je fais partie du même
collectif donc notre travail principal
c'est d'organiser des réseaux de rivera
en fait dans les zones forestières et
les zones rurales où se déroulent de la
chasse à courre pour faire remonter tout
ce qui est les désagréments les
débordements de cette pratique
particulière de chasse et ils sont
nombreux donc notre collectif est
justement née d'une mobilisation
populaire suite dans les villages ruraux
suite des graves incidents qui ont
opposé les populations ou aux chasseurs
à courre et donc par endroit pour parler
de la méthode un peu comment est ce
qu'on fait remonter les informations par
endroit certains habitants se portent
volontaires pour suivre directement les
chasses à courre pendant le déroulement
parmi les chasseurs donc l'intérêt ses
sorties c'est avant tout de pouvoir
documenter au plus près ce mode de
chasse qui est peu connue en fait pour
pourra vraiment reconnaître le
déroulement et surtout c'est de pouvoir
anticiper les problèmes et prévenir à
temps les populations qui vont être
concernés par peut-être des débordements
et les autorités compétentes donc
jusqu'ici cette mission de contrôle avec
raison beaucoup traité lors des
précédentes auditions des modes de
chasse les plus fréquents et en fait les
plus efficaces en termes quantitatifs
pour ce qui est de la régulation des
espèces mais il en existe d'autres comme
la chasse à courre donc qui malgré leur
participation infime au plan de chasse
pour la chasse à courre là on parle par
exemple de 0,1 pour cent des sangliers
qui sont abattus chaque année et en
termes aussi d'effectifs c'est tout
aussi négligeable la chasse à courre ça
concerne 0 1% des chasseurs en général
et bien qu'ils ont un impact absolument
disproportionné sur la sécurité des
populations rurales donc pour résumer le
temps qui nous est imparti pour ce
propos introductif est assez réduit donc
je vais juste posé un plan de mes deux
noms de nos remarques d'abord il faut
poser le décor de ce qu'est la chasse à
courre celle de chaska qui est cassé
plus connu ça consiste en la poursuite
d'un animal sauvage avec une meute de
chiens avec dans l'idéal la plus faible
participation possible des humains qui
l'encadrent cavaliers ou piéton qui en
cas de la meute seulement au son des
cris dans l'idéal écrit décor et du
bruit du fouet en moyenne aucune chasse
à courre auxerre pour prendre un exemple
mobile et une centaine de personnes sur
place ce soit des chasseurs ou des
spectateurs qu'on appelle les suiveurs
et que ce soit en 4 4 à vélo avec des
poids lourds pour déplacer les montures
et à cheval ou à pied une fois lâché les
chiens de la meute entre 20 et 50 ça
dépend de l'animal chassé pour suivre
des animaux plusieurs animaux bien sûr
qu'ils croisent tout au long de la
journée et si on additionnait salle
vacarme causé par les cris les corps les
nombreux véhicules on peut comprendre
qu'une chasse à courre puisse générer un
certain chaos et ce sur un large
périmètre en fait on on y reviendra plus
tard lors
c'est là dessus qu'on a concentré sur
notre exposé j'ai pas mal de points au
dessus donc c'est périmé de chasse à
courre il évolue en fait en plus tout le
long de la journée parce que la chasse à
courre c'est un phénomène qui est très
mobile et dont le déplacement édictées
et ça c'est une spécificité non pas par
les chasseurs eux-mêmes mais par la
dette qui est traqué les chasseurs et
leurs meutes le fond que le poursuivre
ce qui rend assez imprévisible le
déplacement de la chasse est donc le
type créer des conflits d'usagé avec les
usagers de la forêt ou du lot de chasse
donc notons aussi c'est très important
pour la suite ce qui va se dire
contrairement à ce que la légende
pourrait laisser croire c'est de chasser
aussi bien usage d'armes à feu que
d'armes blanches même des fois plusieurs
armes même animal donc le choix des
armes utilisées se fait d'ailleurs
toujours sur le tas dans l'improvisation
du moment comme certaines vidéos
récentes ont pu le montrer donc notre
autre exposé il va se il va se baser
principalement sur plusieurs
constatations en termes de sécurité 1
d'abord le partage de la forêt pour
faire très court les chasses à courre
les grande vénerie en tout cas se
déroulent sur des grands espaces des
forêts domaniales entières qui sont
réservées pour des journées entières ce
qui fait que ça rentre absolument
imprévisible contrairement aux chats se
dire qu'ils sont sur des petites
parcelles pendant quelques heures les
rencontres des promeneurs avec les
chiens ou les animaux sauvages qui
courent en panique et ce n'est qu'un des
points 2 et le
les fréquents débordements sur les
routes aussi nous depuis la création de
notre jeune collectif on a pu recenser
au moins 23 accident de voiture causé
directement par la suite d'animaux
sauvages ou des chiens de meute que ça
toutes les forêts domaniales en plus
critiquée bien sûr mais son parcours ou
de routes souvent à 80 km/heure jeu ça
cause beaucoup de problèmes et le
dernier point sur lequel on appuiera et
ça c'est sûrement ce qui vient le plus
vite à l'esprit quand on parle de chasse
à courre en ce moment c'est les
débordements des équipages sur les zones
hors des zones de chasse en fait c'est à
dire dans les zones urbanisées dans les
lieux de travail sur les zones
touristiques donc on a une certain
nombre de recommandations pour qu'ils
nous semblent des recommandations
d'urgence en fait pourquoi liées aux
primes de sécurité même si nous
l'expérience nous fait dire que le seul
moyen d'arriver au risque zéro c'est
l'abolition de cette pratique simple
merci
bonjour
marie moi je suis le directeur adjoint
de la fondation brigitte bardot qui est
une organisation
généraliste donc on travaille sur
l'animal sauvage comme l'animal
domestique donc c'est une formation qui
a été reconnue d'utilité publique en
1992 et parmi les nos administrateurs il
ya des représentants trois ministères
donc l'intérieur l'écologie et
l'agriculture
donc on travaille beaucoup effectivement
aussi sur la problématique chassa et
vous aviez probablement entendu parler
l'année dernière de la campagne de
sensibilisation
sur les la sécurité des accidents de
chasse donc qui était avec la crosse
chasseurs restez chez vous enfin sauver
des vies restez chez vous en reprenant
les chiffres de l'ojd b donc sur le
nombre d'accidents et de morts de la
chasse à et pour ce qui est de l'objet
donc de cette mission en fait on aurait
voulu aussi parler bon évidemment je
rejoins ce qui a été dit sur des jours
sans chasse mais aussi qu'elles sont le
type de victimes des accidents de chasse
alors lorsqu'on avait lancé la campagne
l'année dernière d'affichage
effectivement on avait fait aussi une
enquête d'opinion sur justement le
sentiment de sécurité ou d'insécurité
des français au moment des périodes de
chasse et donc à la question vous sentez
vous en sécurité lorsque vous vous
promenez dans la nature en période de
chasse les français étaient alors 21 29%
répondent oui contre 71% à se sentir en
insécurité
c'était un chiffre stable par rapport à
la précédente
opération qui était de 2017 mais qui a
beaucoup évolué depuis 2009 puisque à
l'époque on était sur une réponse de 46
% de français se sentir en sécurité
contre seulement 29 % aujourd'hui alors
l'une des pistes ce qui a déjà été
abordé c'est effectivement de
d'instaurer une ou plusieurs journées
sans chasse jusqu'à présent on interrogé
les français sur la mise en place d'une
journée sans chasse le dimanche et là on
a fait une nouvelle étude qui dont on a
eu des résultats ce matin en reprenant
les propositions de yannick jadot à
savoir deux jours sans chasse dont le
dimanche plus les vacances scolaires et
là on est quand même sur 83 % des
français qui sont favorables à cette
demande
et puis alors justement là où je voulais
en venir moi tout à l'heure quand on
parle de sentiment d'insécurité alors il
y avait évidemment toutes les victimes
humaines mais pas uniquement on a aussi
de notre côté puisque nous on n'est pas
compétent pour intervenir sur un
accident qui touche un particulier en
revanche on est très sollicités par des
particuliers dont les animaux se soient
animaux de compagnie ou animaux
d'élevage sont victimes aussi de tir et
là j'ai demandé justement un autre
juriste doit faire un point sur les
trois dernières années on s'est
constituée partie civile sur 250
procédure et il faut savoir que ça c'est
une toute petite partie parce que la
plupart du tour les les chasseurs ne
poussant pas poursuivi parce qu'on
considère qu' il n'y avait pas une
atteinte volontaire
sur l'animal qui a été tué ou blessé
donc c'est énormément de témoignages
d'accidents qui se passe et il faut être
conscient que ça ça participe justement
à la fracture en milieu rural entre les
chasseurs et non chasseurs d'ailleurs
parfois c'est aussi ils se sont aussi
des chasseurs qui sont victimes de ces
tirs mais le fait que effectivement les
chasseurs ne soit pas plus vigilants et
entraîne la mort d'animaux de chevaux
aux deux chevaux de chats de chiens
évidemment et pas simplement par les
tirs on a beaucoup de témoignages aussi
de nos deux chiens qui ne sont pas
encadrées et qui s'attaque alors on a eu
dans les derniers temps pas mal
d'exemples avec des lamas sais pas
pourquoi mais les lamas étaient
particulièrement attaquées par des
chiens donc éventré plusieurs élevages
qui ont été touchés par des chiens de
meute et donc c'était un point où on
pourra revenir plus en détail ensuite
n'est que je voulais aborder parce que
on n'en parle jamais et pourtant ça fait
véritablement partie aussi des raisons
pour lesquelles il ya un gros problème
de sentiment d'insécurité avec des gens
qui se retrouvent avec leur chat qui a
été déchiqueté par par une meute de
chiens ou je vous dis un cheval ou un
veau ou n'importe quoi qui sert au
dessus et ben des cartouches à des tirs
non contrôlée donc voilà donc non on
pourra y revenir mais je vous dis par
rapport aux toutes les procédures qu'on
engage sa montre qu'il ya un réel aussi
mal être et malaise par rapport à cette
situation de terre
merci beaucoup
en passant en visio peut-être
humanité et biodiversité
un bélier
bonjour
sandrine bélier je suis la directrice de
l'association humanité et biodiversité
je suis accompagné de lucie mendes notre
chargé d'une mission
politique dédiée dédiée à la
biodiversité d'abord madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur je
voulais vous remercier vous remercier
pour cette audition et puis vous
remercier de vous est saisi de cette
question et d'avoir donné suite à cette
pétition citoyenne en organisant cette
mission sénatoriale vous présentez
l'humanité biodiversité en deux mots
c'est une association qui a été créée en
1976 on tient le plus de 40 ans qui est
reconnue d'utilité publique dont l'adage
est la biodiversité partout pour tous et
avec tous failli coa à ce que les uns et
les autres ont pu et donc c'est jusqu'à
présent et notre activité s'articule
autour de deux modes d'action d'une part
le plaidoyer la sensibilisation ce que
nous faisons aujourd'hui et et d'autre
part l'animation d'un réseau d'oasis
nature qui est un réseau de refuge de
nature ou la chasse n'est pas autorisée
et nous avons eu un peu plus de 600
oasis nature sur sur le territoire
français nous avait demandé de mettre
l'accent sur ce qui nous tenait à coeur
moi je vais vous dire 103,4 points
ce qui tient à coeur à humanité et
biodiversité et qu'on a de cesse de
répéter notamment dans le cadre du cncf
un siège avec l'aele et au et france
nature environnement
c'est que pour nous les pratiques de
chasse d'une part ne doivent pas
compromettre la viabilité des espèces
qui sont connus vulnérables seraient pas
encore été évoquée mais aujourd'hui
qu'on mette fin aux pratiques de chasse
des espèces qui sont considérés en
mauvais état de conservation on est en
france je pense que mon collègue yves
vérilhac peut-être aussi là dessus
on chasse 64 espèces d'oiseaux alors que
la moyenne européenne est de 24 donc
voilà un des premiers éléments qui nous
tient particulièrement à coeur qu'on
réduise la liste des espèces chassées
aujourd'hui sur le territoire français
et notamment pour marc est de chasser
les espèces qui sont en mauvais état de
conservation
le deuxième point qui nous tient
particulièrement à coeur c'est que les
pratiques de chasse aujourd'hui ne
devrait pas ne devrait plus être cause
de souffrance inutile et évitable aux
animaux sauvages et ça en trois points
déjà d'une part on s'interroge et se
départit de nos actes de pellouailles et
de pour un statut d'être sensible aux
animaux sauvages aujourd'hui il ya une
aberration les animaux d'élevage type au
lièvre garenne faisant dès lors qu'ils
sont engagés les ondes un statut d'être
sensible et dès lors qu'ils sont
relâchés ne l'ont plus ça c'est le
premier point la fin des chasses
traditionnelles et puis a dit quand même
on le sait tout ça a été évoqué la fin
des pratiques comme les déterrage de
blaireaux et est une des choses qui nous
tient particulièrement à coeur et si je
devais donner un troisième élément donc
y en aura mais en fait je me permets de
choses dedans c'est ce qui vous
intéresse et la sécurité à la chasse là
vous êtes en train de faire un plaidoyer
sur donc effectivement la chasse et sur
un type de chasse vraiment
cette mission à un objectif et une vue
de cette mission c'est de pouvoir
travailler réfléchir et partager des
propos sur la sécurité à la chasse est
dans les tons qu'il est un parti je
voulais vous profiter juste de
l'invitation de la présidente à nous
faire part de ce qui nous tenait à coeur
j'aurais dû me tenir à une élément et
ceci étant dit il a été évoqué donc je
vais cibler mon propos notamment sur
cinq propositions pour renforcer la
sécurité dans le cadre des battus
puisque nos collègues l'ont dit à la
bleue mance et les circonstances de
chasse qui pose le plus sont plus cause
d'accidents aujourd'hui cinq
propositions sur lesquelles on aura
l'occasion certainement devenir la
première une professionnalisation
renforcer d acteur débattu et des
chasseurs il ya un rapport de règles de
consignes avant chaque battue la seconde
proposition qu'on vous soumet et celle
d'accorder une attention particulière au
bon entretien des armes ça a été évoqué
également les défaillances mécaniques
sont souvent cause d'accident la
troisième de troisième élément est qu'on
vous ce sommet est le fait de prévoir un
périmètre de sécurité ça a été évoqué
aussi également non chassable notamment
autour des habitations attenantes et
puis quatrième proposition
déployés sur le souligne régulièrement
au sein du conseil d'administration de
l'office français de la biodiversité on
a besoin de plus de moyens humains et
financiers pour que la police de
l'environnement soient en mesure
d'effectuer davantage de contrôles et
puis enfin dernière la dernière
proposition que je soumets à votre
attention en attendant le débat et la
table ronde en cas de manquement ou de
négligence ou d'imprudence avérée nous
soutenons également que la suspension du
permis de chasse devrait être
systématique voilà ce stade de la
discussion ce que je souhaitais partager
avec vous merci beaucoup leur monsieur
vérilhac
oui
merci mont rouge elle avait eu une
association qui fête ses 110 ans qui
fument à sablons faire un concours avec
avec eux sans blinky à 60k la 1000
adhérents 8000 bénévoles ça sent
cinglante sera y ait en france elle
n'est pas contre la chasse contrairement
à ce qu'on pourrait penser en lisant les
médias les contre ses excès ses abus et
dérives
tout simplement parce que nous nous
attaquerons encore d'effondrement des
universités et que les prélèvements
excessifs selon l'inpes le sens sol un
la deuxième chose la france sandrine à
me dit est parmi les mauvais élèves de
l'europe en matière de
deux constats sur les accidents
très rapidement au risque d'énerver mes
collègues
on s'en sort pas trop mal on regarde le
nombre de pratiques alors madame la
présidente non c'est pas plus de 2
millions si vous voulez bien ne pas
suivre les six fois delà des
manifestants et ceux de la police selon
le web et qui enregistre les données
rnis et 984 me lavais ligne verte devra
qu'avant mobile permis par an donc à
rennes ne faisons pas de voile
inutile de chiffres gonflés ces 985 mais
on sait moins de 1 million oui bien
céder demi en cinq ans en 1970
il ya relativement peu d'accidents ceci
dit on peut regretter deux on voit des
courbes décembre sans aucune modération
du nombre de chasseurs justement des
techniques de chasse du nombre d'heures
de chasse c'est pas la même chose à ce
beau cinéma la course en ligne élite
rica km et une balle de 2-2 hier qu'a
dit donc c'est comme si on comparait les
accidents de voiture ans on peut à 1977
dont deux chevaux et locales faisaient
aujourd'hui maintenant les choses ont
changé donc on peut pas faire comme le
fait de louer des présentations sans
nuance et la deuxième c'est celle de
l'acceptabilité oui la société ne
supporte pas
des gens qui se font face actuellement
une arme par une grande chasse c'est
moins choquant pour la société les
accidents de ski où les accidents de
tous les actions de cheval même si c'est
vrai aussi avec des skis ou avec des
chevaux
mais moi ils me sens que la poigne
beaucoup plus grave est celui de la
détention d armes de chasse et de
l'absence de contrôle de cette arme et
des munitions
il correspond qui conduisait à bord et
chaque année sur les morts par suicide
ou par féminicide abrite 500 morts par
exemple des tenues des armes de chasse
n'est tenu en france dont des pannes de
couple qui se déchire bien dire des
enfants qui sont victimes quand il
connaît personnellement et je pense à
vous soucier de la détention des flammes
on regarde toujours les faits
d'ingrédients qui sont celles du
problème mais qu'ils ont vraiment marre
et de plusieurs centaines de morts
benefit sac parce que il est à la maison
cueillette des cartouches et que la côte
est que la personne et des lessives la
course au fusil parce qu'il n'y a pas de
limite et le mellick mais c'est allé
beaucoup plus loin sur le sujet je
voudrais juste avec bochum est vraiment
beaucoup de respect monsieur le je
voudrais bien vous dire que on est un
souci en france c'est celui du lobby
cynégétique jusqu'au sommet de l'état et
beaucoup au parlement et beaucoup au
sénat non nous avons dit gérard larcher
ya pas longtemps à intervenir auprès
loiselet pour nous menacer de supplément
de pension à ce qu'un texte dans une
plaquette décidé au début ne plaisait
pas
quand je vois et encore une fois
vraiment ne le prenez pas pour vous
comme ça monsieur le sénateur mélenchon
moi vous avez voté pour l'élargissement
des dérogations pour autoriser l'achat
des douanes aux migrateurs est contraire
à la directive rohs
surclassé les chefs traditionnels comme
patrimoine national pour laisser le
terme sable dans l'intitulé de l'om mais
vous allez vous tirer lorsque la
broye donc je vous prie hilton monsieur
le sénateur est ce que vous faites
totalement objective sur la question de
la chasse mais très monsieur tout
d'abord ce n'est pas vous qui allez
assez bien mais c'est un film ici mais
de notation
une pétition d'astuces il rappelé
écoutez moi si si donc effectivement je
suis ici c'est que je pense que mes
collègues ont considéré que j'avais les
qualités pour pouvoir mener cette
mission en tant que rapporteur est en
tout cas ce n'est sûrement pas à vous
d'en juger vous avez le droit de penser
ce que vous voulez aujourd'hui on est là
pour parler de sécurité à la chasse je
souhaiterais qu'on reste sur le sujet
je vous défendez vous défendez une des
choses qui sont contre la directive
oiseaux et vous venez et vous êtes sensé
répond notre vous écoutez excusez moi
mais ça pose même démocratique ex bonne
humeur voilà ces brevets
en mettant en doute déjà à l'intégrité
des travaux des parlementaires qui sont
sur cette table très franchement fallait
pas venir
piger droits nouveaux sont beaucoup de
rester est ce que j'ai le droit est ce
que vous pouvez me rassurer c'est
possible qui dort effectivement je m'en
vais je quitte le truc c'est simon dit
effet dimanche de mode pour l'agnm
chasse au printemps pour et vous pouvez
compter sur moi pour être objectif le
dit monsieur je n'ai pas à m'expliquer
de mes votes mais je vais quand même
vous dire une chose c'est que chaque
fois que j'ai voté je vais faire mon âme
et conscience par rapport à un certain
nombre de propos et c'est pour moi toute
la qualité du travail parlementaire
je comprends les gens qui soient pas
d'accord avec nos positions et enoh donc
vote mais quand on le fait on le fait en
fonction d'éléments qui nous sont donc
parvenus par le travail qu'on peut
réaliser en prenant donc les avis des
uns et des autres et à un moment il faut
trancher et à un moment il faut prendre
une position après qu elles ne plaisent
pas à tout le monde j'en suis convaincu
je les dis pas plus tard que la semaine
dernière dans un
reportage ou plutôt
non c'est une interrogation de deux
journalistes en disant c'est quand j'ai
donc accepté de prendre ce rôle de
rapporteur de cette mission je savais
qu'au bout du compte je n'aurai que des
ennemis passe je suis persuadé que les
chasseurs pense exactement la même chose
que vous ou qui le pense ou après
l'édition notre rapport alors on va
essayer de travailler avec sérieux comme
on le fait ici dans cette maison et
faire en sorte qu' on est un maximum
d'amis voilà voilà voilà un autre enjeu
voilà notre objectif est de challenge
voilà
maintenant si vous voulez bien à la
chasse et je peux vous dire que je ferai
le travail avec vraiment tout le sérieux
qui est le mien et celui de mes
collègues a puni on vous a fait
confiance puisqu'on est là monsieur le
sénateur je me dis juste que le père
tente de l'assemblée nationale confie
une mission sur le problème des
sangliers elle le confie alain péréa
grand chasseur devant l'éternel et donc
je vous dis on n'a pas de clients de nhs
et platinum derrière nous avec une
édition citoyenne et que nous nous
sommes développés et totalise sommes
huit aveyron le des partis politiques
si nous sommes indûment
aux
énoncés aussi
les mérites de la charge ont vraiment
confiance vous rassurer je me donne des
idées nos achats sur
écoute
bon je vous confirme que le dimanche
sans chasse est une des meilleures
solutions pour progresser et nous
espérons que ça sera retenu par votre
commission
oui
bonjour bonjour à tous donc je suis
sabine ira-t-elle où je représente le
mouvement des roues en colère je vous
remercie de nous recevoir et de de nous
entendre j'espère
donc nous représentons en fait nous nous
défendons les humains il ya des
associations qui défendent les animaux
ici autour de cette table nous nous
défendons les 21,4 millions de ruraux
qui ne chasse pas il existe aussi on
entend souvent parler de la ruralité qui
est assimilée et qui serait assimilée à
la chasse il y à 21,4 millions de ruraux
qui ne chasse pas et qui sont une des
premières victimes de la chasse
puisqu'ils subissent chaque jour
quasiment dans leur vie quotidienne des
mises en danger dans leur maison dans
leurs jardins dans leurs loisirs en dans
leurs déplacements liés à l'achat ce qui
est le loisir d'une ultra minorité de 2%
de la population
donc nous représentons ces personnes là
nous les défendons nous essayons de leur
donner de la visibilité parce que si on
ne parle pas des 21,4 millions d euros
non chasseurs c'est parce que il n'ya
pas de lobby ou de groupements d'intérêt
commun c'est une population qui est
assez diverses par ses centres
d'intérêts mise à part son seul point
commun c'est de vivre à la campagne et
d'essayer d'y vivre bien et donc nous
essayons à la fois de porter leur voix
et
également de les rendre visibles et de
rendre visible la réalité c'est ce que
je voudrais vraiment vous faire
comprendre la réalité de
l'ampleur du problème de ce qu'on
appelle l'insécurité rural qui est liée
à la chasse donc vous avez entendu mes
collègues vous ont parlé à plusieurs
reprises des sondages les sondages sont
vraiment clair et vous donne une idée
certainement de la façon dont vous
pouvez vous faire beaucoup d'amis
puisque vous voyez que 83% encore après
avec le sondage de la fondation brigitte
bardot et ce 83% se rapprochent
exactement du sondage de one voice en
septembre dernier 83 perse % des
français de monde
deux jours sans chasse par semaine c'est
quelque chose qui selon les différents
sondages revient de façon stable donc
vous avez les moyens de vous faire 83%
d'amis avec une mesure relativement
simple à mettre en place et qui en plus
ne coûtera rien ou presque rien au
budget de l'état donc je vois là une
proposition qui j'espère retiendra votre
attention et donc je voulais surtout
vous parler d'eux parce que donc c'est
sondage reflète un sentiment
d'insécurité moi je voulais vous montrer
la réalité de cette insécurité et je
vous ai fait passer ce matin un document
puisque nous nous recensons
les accidents et incidents liés à la
chasse touchant des non chasseurs c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas fait par ou
qui n'est pas distingué en tant que tel
et pour cela nous nous basons uniquement
sur des faits avérés donc là pas de
chasseurs qui va nous envoyer des
témoignages bidon et des choses comme ça
nous nous basons uniquement sur des
articles de presse des
publications avec des photos ou des
vidéos et donc ça nous amène à écarter
beaucoup de témoignages mais malgré cela
on arrive quand même depuis le début de
cette saison de chasse à 90 accidents et
incidents qui touchent des non chasseurs
cela représente un accident ou incident
tous les 1,8 jour presque toutes ou
presque tous les jours ou en tout cas
plus souvent que tous les deux jours il
ya un problème est signalé avéré ça se
répartit en
malheureusement une personne tuée c'est
ce malheureux automobiliste à l'ail et
seize noms chasseur blessé par une
action de chasse depuis sept ans
21 animaux domestiques et je vois que la
première confrontation gibbard doit bien
plus mais nous on en a trouvé que 21
dans les dents mais dans les journaux et
les publications 19 tirs sur des maisons
ou des voitures
16 nos respects de la propriété privée
et menacent
15 mise en danger du public et entrave
aux loisirs et des classements donc 88
au total donc ça représente un accident
tous les huit jours un non chasseurs
blessés tous les dix jours un animal
domestique blesser ou tuer chaque
semaine et donc incluse un tir sur une
maison une voiture tous les huit jours
donc vous vous promenez vous allez ou
alors vous avez simplement travailler
vous risquez de vous faire tirer dessus
dans votre voiture un au respect de la
propriété et vous des menaces tout et
dix jours et une mise en danger du
public presque tous les dix jours donc
ça c'est la réalité de ce que vivent 21
points 4 millions de personnes en france
à cause de la chasse donc à cause du
loisir de 2% de la population
ça
ça touche à des droits vraiment
fondamentaux de ses citoyens les ruraux
sont des citoyens comme les autres et
ils ont des droits comme les autres qui
doivent être garantis par la déclaration
des droits de l'homme la déclaration des
droits de l'homme c'est l'article 1er
les hommes naissent et demeurent libres
et égaux en droits ces droits sont la
liberté la propriété et la sûreté la
liberté on a vu que 76% des ruraux
renoncent à se promener à cause de la
chasse donc la liberté est bafouée la
propriété est bafouée puisque ma
collègue a évoqué la loi verdeille qui
impose aux
audi 1500 communes aux dix mille cent il
ya ça c'est quelque chose qui a si peu
connu les acca ça représente un tiers du
territoire français sur un tiers du
territoire français 10500 commune si
vous êtes propriétaire de votre maison
et doit de jardin votre jardin d'office
est intégré dans le territoire de chasse
sans votre accord donc votre droit de
propriété est bafouée et la sûreté bien
sûr on l'a vu et est bafouée c'est un
enjeu de démocratie
j'aurais également
bien sûr je j'évoque très rapidement
aussi la deuxième partie de mon exposé
qui était sur l'impossibilité pour les
règles actuelles de chasse de garantir
la sécurité des riverains donc avec le
affichant que monsieur évoqué ce tir
fichant il faut savoir que même quand il
est correctement effectuée il ricoche
quasiment systématiquement c'est un
expert qui l'a at il évoqué monsieur
joël certes mais pas
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous merci
madame la présidente et monsieur le
rapporteur de nous donner cette
opportunité
de présenter notre association et notre
position aujourd'hui donc l'association
one voice est une association de défense
des animaux et de l'environnement qui a
été créée en 1995 et concernant la
chasse elle milite pour une réforme
radicale de la chasse notamment un
meilleur encadrement de la pratique et
des sanctions plus sévères en cas de
manquement pourquoi ne voyais cela la
chasse représenter un danger en tant que
telle elle est opposée en ce sens mais
aujourd'hui donc je me limiterai à
développer les considérations concernant
la sécurité de la chasse puisque nous
sommes là pour en discuter donc comme on
l'a dit accident de chasse victimes
collatérales qu'elle soit animale ou
humaine ou encore un sécurité des
usagers de la nature et thématiques sur
l'insécurité de la chasse sont assez
diverses et au centre aujourd'hui du
débat public et ça fait de très
nombreuses années que les associations
et puis les citoyens
oeuvre sur cette thématique et se
mobilisent pour dénoncer les abus donc
je voudrais juste mentionné pour débuter
effectivement les sondages qui ont été
mentionné que je vous transmettrai si
vous souhaitez à la fin de la fin de
cette audition dont queen's a fait
réaliser deux sondages le premier en
2018 le second en septembre 2021 afin de
voir quelle est la perception des
français autour des thématiques de la
chasse et quelle est leur positionnement
justement faire par rapport à un
meilleur encadrement éventuellement une
modification de la législation
l'intérêt de réaliser un sondage à trois
ans d'intervalle sa ferme est justement
de voir la permanence des
positionnements éventuellement
l'évolution va justement de la
perception des français pour citer
quelques exemples ont été donnés
effectivement n'en avait 82 % en
septembre 2021 de français qui étaient
favorables
à l'interdiction de la chasse
deux jours par semaine dont le dimanche
et l'intégralité des vacances scolaires
n'a également de 83% des sondés qui
pensent que la chasse pose effectivement
problème en terme de sécurité pour les
promeneurs lors des balades dans la
nature et on à 76% des sondés qui
habitent près d'une zone de chasse qui
se disent éviter de ceux qui disent
pardon éviter de se promener dans l'est
dans certaines zones de peur d'un
accident de chasse donc on voit
effectivement qu'il ya une évolution
favorable des français vers plus
d'encadrement ou du moins voilà une
modification de la législation actuelle
concernant la sécurisation de la de la
chasse il s'agit bien d'une réalité
vécue nous on souhaite aussi à accentuer
le fait que ça va au delà du clivage
urbains ruraux puisqu'on voit dans le
sondage aussi que cette insécurité cette
inquiétude elle se manifeste aussi bien
dans les territoires urbanisés ou
périurbain que dans les territoires
ruraux
grâce au sondage de 2018 on a lancé une
pétition qui reprend dix points dont
pour une réforme radicale de la chasse
dont 2 notamment sont des réformes
concernant la sécurisation de cette
pratique donc le premier c'est
l'obligation d'une visite médicale
annuelle notamment un contrôle de la vue
dans ce cadre nous on est favorable à ce
que la chasse soit ajouté parmi la liste
des sports qui présente des contraintes
particulières au sens de l'article l 231
tiré de code du sport ce qui
impliquerait notamment l'obligation de
produire un certificat médical
d'aptitude à la pratique donc il ya déjà
été mentionné notamment un contrôle de
l'acuité visuelle tous les ans par
exemple est également donc deux jours
deux par semaine sans chasse donc
dimanche et toutes les vacances
scolaires donc cette pétition est en
ligne actuellement elle est à plus de
trente trois cent mille signatures
pour terminer je voudrais juste
mentionné donc les enquêtes qui sont
menées par l'association one voice car
pour nous elles sont aussi révélatrice
de certains manquements concernant la
sécurité de la chasse donc l'association
one voice réalise des enquêtes en
infiltration dans le domaine de la
chasse dans différents domaines que ce
soit à chasse à courre la chasse en
enclos le piégeage comme cela a été
mentionné ou les battues administratives
et nos enquêteurs donc en infiltré ce
milieu pendant près de trois ans
ces images qui n'ont pu être publiées à
la fois pour sensibiliser public mais
aussi à destination du pouvoir public
parce que l'objectif c'est justement que
quelques l alerte le législateur pour
éventuellement prendre des actes
concernant ces manquements
pour donner quelques exemples les
enquêtes ont pu mettre en avant des
comportements d'alcoolémie parfois dès 8
heures du matin cédant certaines chasses
un certain mépris envers les autres
usagers de la nature une forte
culpabilisation des autres usagers
lorsqu'il ya des incidents des règles de
sécurité notamment lors de battues qui
sont données de manière non explicites
ou partielle et avec une forte
hétérogénéité en fonction des
territoires et notamment des accidents
de la route comme ça a été mentionné
avec des animaux sauvages ou des chiens
donc voilà l'objectif pour nous de
mentionner notre travail d'enquêté de
montrer un fort retentissement
médiatique c'est une chose mais notre
souhait c'est vraiment que ce soit pris
en compte aussi dans la sueur la partie
législation voilà merci
merci à vous
bien alors ce tour de table
et en étant fait donc je proposais de
revenir sur un certain nombre de points
donc et peut-être pour
sorte de hiérarchie zélés les sujets je
vais donc
vous poser une question ou des questions
sur un sujet et puis je vous demanderai
de réagir en fonction évidemment de
l'évolution de chacun ce que je tiens à
dire de façon très précise c'est que les
propos je pourrais tenir pour poser mes
questions ne sont en rien des positions
ce que je souhaite ici c'est qu'on
puisse vraiment donc avoir un débat un
débat en fonction donc de propos tenus
autour de cette table ronde le propos
tenus autour d'eux d'autres tables
rondes puisque ces travaux donc se passe
sur un temps donc assez long avec des
rencontres de d'acteurs divers
donc j'insiste sur ce point pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de malentendu alors il ya un
point qui revient assez fréquemment dans
les propos liminaires c'est
les jours de chasse je veux permettre de
commencer par par ce point là ce n'était
pas le plus simple mais
il est revenu le plus souvent dans
autour de cette table ça me paraît
important de l'évoquer notamment sur
l'interdiction de un jour de chasse nous
avons auditionné les fédérations donc de
sport de nature
qui en fait sont apparus
partager ensemble plutôt
défavorable à la mise en place donc d'un
l'interdiction de la gironde échasses
avec
donc des
arguments que que je répète ici qui
était dire mais finalement si on
interdit un jour de chasse
cf tous les autres jours sont autorisés
et donc dû finalement non mais je je je
me permets volontairement encore une
fois de poser le débat
en disant voilà si si on dit la chasse
est à dire le dimanche ça veut dire que
tous les autres jours les chasseurs ont
libre accès et c'est aux autres de se
retirer donc le risque est quand même de
déséquilibrer l'accès à la nature
première chose deuxième chose c'est dire
si on interdit la chasse le dimanche
est-ce que c'est pas pour aller vers
l'interdiction des vtt le samedi et
c'était donc je pose le problème est la
question en ces termes pour pour qu'on
puisse justement apporter les arguments
et les uns et les autres et qu'on puisse
en faire la synthèse donc voilà donc
pour commencer peut-être le sujet que je
souhaiterais donc aborder en l'étendant
peut-être en disant qu' on peut se poser
la question aussi des zones sans chasse
notamment des secteurs touristiques qui
mérite peut-être justement que dans les
périodes de touristique on puisse donc
interdire la chasse à proximité des
circuits de grande randonnée
et cetera des recyclables voilà donc la
relance ce débat donc réagi c'est donc
peut-être une façon peut-être
volontaires faire en sorte de refaire un
tour de table
voilà et est rapidement
à bien pour les jours de chasse en
disant plus la chasse à se déplacer d'un
jour sur l'autre c'est tout c'est une
hypothèse certes mais la seule façon de
savoir c'est de faire des tests c'est à
dire testé sur le long terme à savoir
s'il se passe comme ça personnellement
moi je le peux je ne le pense pas mais
on peut pas dire je m'interdis je ne
m'interdis pas un jour de chaque jour
aux soins jours sans chasse en disant
que ça va se déplacer ça c'est une chose
c'est pas se déplacer c'est dire qu'à
part du moment où il y en a un qui a
interdit tous les autres sont autorisés
et donc je voyais renner de l'espace
autour de
la question laisse question c'est que
c'est autorisé n'importe comment c'est
autorisé de chasse je veux plus combien
de timo dix mois sur douze en france
alors que c'est tu sais tu n'as c'est
une aberration mais parce que ça a
évolué de l'ouverture et des fermetures
de chasse qui a été explosée et là j'ai
rejoint
riaa qui dit qu'il ya un lobby
puisqu'ils demandent des réglementations
à la demande comme ça qui est ça qui
sont faites et je veux pas repartir sur
la police j'y reviendrai parce que c'est
important et sur les zones les zones de
chasse au savoir que dans les réserves
naturelles les les promeneurs ont moins
de droits que les chasseurs à dire que
vous promener avec un chien ne serait ce
qu en s vous prenez un pv dans certaines
réserves et les salles arrive avec un 5
à 4 et lâcheté chien donc d'abord la
sécurité évidemment ce que les chasseurs
chasse dans les réserves nous ont ce
qu'on demande c'est que les réserves
soient exonérés de chasse surtout jeu
c'est à dire que je rejoins yves
vérilhac c'est à dire que y'a quand même
aussi aux faut sécuriser la chasse il
faut que la chasse ne mettent pas en
danger tout un tas de domaines qui nous
concerne
et quand on sait qu'il ya 4 % 4 % c'est
le nombre de de space sauvage par
rapport à 96% des animaux domestiques et
nous mêmes c'est alors cessé 4% sont
absolument essentiel à notre survie
c'est à dire celle là il faut bien il
faut câble a préservé tandis que les
tiers des oiseaux tôt disparu en
quelques années donc je pense que pour
la sécurité des personnes il faut qu'ils
étaient vraiment des zones sans chasse
et que ce soit dans les réserves les
réserves soient sans chasse et vous soit
pas autorisé à faire des battues ya des
gens qui sont bien l'abri dans des
réserves qui sont fait flinguer quand
même donc voilà je joue et
je comprends pas en fait cet argument
parce que si c'est de dire on interdit
pas parce que ça autoritaire et les
autres jours alors qu'actuellement
justement problème c'est que c'est
autorisé tous les jours donc justement
ce qu'on donne moi ce que j'ai dit non
mais c'est ce que vous avez
repris est ce que le risque n'est pas
que en sur dix ans il ya un jour sans
chasse on dise en même temps tous les
autres jours sont avec chasse et donc
sont réservés aux chasseurs c'est ça la
question parce qu'on est sur la question
sécurité j'insiste oui mais alors dote
donc donc les usagers dirais non mais ça
n'a pas de sens cet argument donc non
mais en fait c'est simplement ce qu'on
souhaite c'est qu'effectivement il est
des jours non chasse qui se soit qu'ils
soient
réels pour tout le monde pour limiter
les accidents parce que justement les
autres usagers de chasse seront que ce
jour là ils peuvent en profiter sans
risque de se prendre une une balle
perdue mais oui dans la vo dit
exactement ce que je dis c'est à dire
que effectivement ça veut dire que les
gens vont se promener que ce jour là
mais non pas essayer puisque non mais ça
n'est pas le fait qu'ils aient quelques
jours de chasse donc en moins qui va
faire qu'il y aura plus d'accidents cc
by sa limite même seulement quand même
si c'est un dimanche en ce sens chasse
on sait que t'être jour on pourra au
moins se balader toute façon les gens se
baladent pas forcément tous les jours et
puis en l'occurrence ça ne diminue pas
la nécessité de mieux sécuriser l'acte
de chasse effectivement avec les
formations et la gloire manquons
ailleurs mais en moins ce jour-là on
sait que arrêt dayori il y aura
à non plus d'attac sur les animaux dont
je parlais tout à l'heure comme exemple
ben moi je ne comprends même pas en fait
l'opposition non mais vous avez
effectivement donc
je sais pas si on le voit quand on
demande la parole en visio
je réfléchissais et est décrite et
christophe à anticiper anticipées ma
réponse
un tour sens pas sous deux jours sans
chasse n'est pas la réponse au magic est
la seule réponse à la question de
renforcement de sécurisation des
pratiques de chasse d'ailleurs on est
même plutôt sur un autre terrain que la
sécurisation nez et ça a été évoqué par
beaucoup beaucoup d'entre nous cette
après-midi on est sur le partage d'usagé
de la nature en réalité et de répondre
au sentiment d'insécurité que peuvent
connaître d'autres usagers de la nature
des promeneurs et c'est donc cette
question du jour sans chasse
aujourd'hui on peut chasser sept jours
par semaine l'idée d'avoir un jour sans
chasse ou deux jours sans chasse
bon on en a un grande bretagne au
portugal ces mêmes on a inversé le
système cd jour qui sont autorisés à la
chasse donc tous les jours
la chasse est autorisée le jeudi et le
dimanche uniquement en italie ces trois
jours sans chasse donc on voit bien dans
les dents dans les autres pays et les
pays riverains à la france on a cette
possibilité
en tout cas également de faire le choix
qui est des jours où en effet la chasse
n'est pas pratiqué ce qui n'empêchera
pas les chasseurs éventuellement
d'organiser ces gens là sans leur fusil
avec les riverains des inventaires de
voir l'état de la biodiversité ils se
revendiquent eux mêmes les protecteurs
de la biodiversité et bénéficie de
financements pour participer à la
connaissance et aux données
post et la cohabitation et le partage de
la nature entre chasseurs et non
chasseurs ce jour sans chasse ou séjour
sans chasse pour être aussi intéressant
pour développer des opérations ou les
chasseurs il reste sur le terrain mais
non armées ces jours là
et pour pour participer comme je le
disais connaissance et à la préservation
de la biodiversité et partager le
territoire avec les autres usagers de la
nature mais en tout état de cause
l'argument des associations de sports
wii conceptuellement voilà encore une
fois excusez moi mais je encore une fois
c'est un ressenti donc de des changes
s'est il donc
sont pas donc des positionnements sais
c'est effectivement pour alimenter les
échanges avec vous et notamment la
discussion et j'entends donc
effectivement quand on dit c'est
peut-être pas la priorité le jour c'est
surtout donc la méthode le comment on
chasse et kiki et qui est important donc
on verra
plusieurs choses d'abord c'est une
fausse problématique si je vous
comprends bien le fait d'autoriser un
jour sans chasse voudrait dire que les
chasseurs considéré que donc tous les
autres vous que j'ai toujours eu c'est
ça en gros si je vous résume lavalard la
halle alors d'abord on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui j'aime bien parler des
faits des chiffres des dates au jour
d'aujourd'hui le jour sans chasse existe
dans toutes les forêts domaniales il y a
un à deux jours de chasse c'est assez
méconnu
donc voilà donc sert de cervelle
fédération qui ont déjà des jours sans
chasse exactement donc voilà donc
opposant faux problème est ce que ça
veut dire que ce jour là tous les gens
ne se promènent plus et que cela
sécurisé et total n'ont donc voilà on a
la réponse à la question voilà donc ça
on a déjà évacué donc le ce n'est pas le
problème le problème qu'on a évacué dans
tout et non mais ça existe donc voila et
on a laissé
non le problème de la c'est
le problème de la sécurité n'est pas la
chasse le problème de la sécurité ce
sont les accidents et des incidents les
accidents se passe à chaque fois qu'il
ya un mauvais usage des armes et âme et
non pas ce sont des non respects des
règles primo s'il ya le respect des
règles il ne devrait pas y avoir
d'accidents de chasse c'est une chose
secundo donc le problème il est là
formation respect des règles le
troisième problème sur les incidents de
chasse qu'il ya ce sont les débordements
des chasseurs
c'est effectivement la plupart d'entre
nous nous sommes déjà fait tirer sue par
des chasseurs tout à fait gratuitement
quand vous voyez que nous avons été
reçus par madame ah bah on parle pas
nous n'avons pas interrompre une chasse
nous n'avons pas démonté un mirador pour
le simple fait d'avoir été reçus par
madame abat sur son poste facebook
officielle de secrétaire d'état en 36
heures nous avons eu 5000 menace admin m
a personal y compris les menaces de mort
voilà en 36 heures
oui mais ce que je veux dire c'est steam
non mais ils imaginaient je veux dire
c'est en 36 heures sur un poste officiel
vous imaginez ce qu'on reçoit l'ours qui
n'est pas officiel mais le problème il
est ce genre de chose ah ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle les incidents qui se
passent dans la nature contre la nation
en tirent dessus en vous disant que vous
n'avez rien à faire là alors que c'est
pas du tout le cas qu'est ce que vous
voulez faire donc le problème ce sont
les incidents donc c'est ça qui doit
être punie pénalement et effectivement
sur la question des jours ça existe et
ce qui a été soulevée par madame de la
faisait sens effectivement dans les
autres pays ce nom on inverse pas là on
inverse la problématique on dit qu'elles
sont les jours autorisés à la chasse
alors
en fait le problème c'est qu'il n'existe
pas de mesures nationales donc je suis
chez moi avec ma famille je il ya une
éclaircie dans la météo je veux sortir
me promener il faut que j'étudie tous
les sites internet pour comprendre où
est ce que je peux aller me promener
quand quel jour c'est pareil dans la
même lignée on me reproche de ne pas
connaître les panneaux de chasse bon
qu'est-ce qu'il faut il faut passer un
code pour aller se promener en forêt
donc l'idée c'est même si ça existe déjà
il faut que ça existe à une chaîne
nationale et que ce soit uniformisé
sinon le citoyen lambda n'y comprend
plus rien
puisque ce sont les forêts domaniales le
problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas
d'uniformisation entre les jours de
chasse
respect des règles dans ça a été dit les
règles de chasse élémentaire ne
serait-ce que l'identification préalable
de la cible donc voilà bien là que la
question des journaux semble-t-il est un
être un faux débat n'est qu'un accident
se passe ce mercredi au mardi ou jeudi
c'est complètement inopérant à mon avis
c'est plus une question d'information
des usagers des citoyens parce qu'on est
une problématique de cohabitation entre
ceux qui font le l'exercice de chasse et
et les simples citoyens qui se promènent
qui la plupart du temps ne connaissent
absolument pas de l'étape d'ouverture de
fermeture et c'est donc en même temps le
citoyen qui se balade sans savoir qu'il
y aurait une action de chasse il va
peut-être pas se méfier il va peut-être
aller plus profondément dans la forêt
sans savoir qu'il ya une action de
chasse pas non alors il peut entendre
des détonations ils peuvent avoir peur
donc je pense que c'est vraiment une
question
d'information du citoyen de savoir oui
c'était les jours il y a de la chasse
tel autre jour il n'y a pas de chasse
mais il faut qu'ils aient une diffusion
cette information par quel biais je
l'ignorent les arrêtés municipaux parce
que finalement le préfet peut faire son
office mais quand il va à la préfecture
et cédera donc je pensais plus haut
niveau local municipal
je voudrais ajouter quelque chose
alors bon complément dans proposons le
jour de chasse
il ya aussi donc des actions qui sont
nés parce qu'on vous avait parlé de
partage de la nature c'est effectivement
un vrai sujet
il ya donc dans certains départements
ont certains secteurs des chartes qui
sont donc signé entre les différents
utilisateurs
de la nature dans le cadre de leurs
activités est-ce que vous avez vous des
retours ou des avis sur ces questions
aussi de deux chartes oui moi j'ai des
informations c'est que il a été demandé
une harmonisation est les noms des
personnes qui nous dit mais voilà moi je
vais me balader mais installe commune
c'est quand il ya bien ce qui un jour de
manche haas qui n'a pas joué de chasse
est ce que c'était si hétérogène alors
je voudrais question au préfet parce que
c'est rare s'est desserré jadida écoutez
vous pouvez pas mettre sur votre site
les communes où il ya bon mais là n'est
pas le débat du jour en charge tous les
jours très bien et d'autres communes
c'est jeudi qu'on chasse pas d'autres
vendredi me dit un énorme ça c'est
impossible on n'a pas le personnel
donc si vous voulez les préfets après on
reviendra aussi sur la détention d'armes
où ils doivent jouer un rôle mais elle
est prévue les préfets lancé pas si
votre autorité celle de l'autorité de
l'état et préfère donc mais en fait vous
pouvez car nan je pense qu'ils ont à
plusieurs niveaux un rôle à jouer et
d'information et de formation et
d'encadrement
madame parce que
oui c'est bas pour répondre à votre
question très précise c'est qu'en fait
c'est toujours très compliqué de
discuter quand on n'est pas d'accord
vous devez le savoir donc des lieux
comme ça d' échanges entre les
différents usagers de la nature ça
existe très peu voire pas du tout et
c'est bien ça aussi qu'on dénonce ceux
dans les incivilités est ce que ce
serait une bonne idée justement de
provoquer et de rendre obligatoire en
fait oui bah oui parce que de façon la
discussion pour la cohabitation elle est
nécessaire à que chacun mette de l'eau
dans son vin et trouve les trous une
façon de fonctionner en fonction aussi
des territoires c'est il ya des lieux de
discussion comme ça qui sont laissés des
crs on retrouve l'ensemble des parties
prenantes bon il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui en l'état actuel des
choses les cdc façon complètement
déséquilibré et on voit que les
représentations sont pas homogènes mais
des lieux où on arrive à décider
ensemble de ce qu'on pourrait faire en
fonction aussi des contextes locaux ça
pourrait être intéressant avec quand
même une loi nationale qui vient donner
un cadre parce que sinon ça partirait un
peu dans tous les sens en tout cas aussi
pour revenir à la question à l'avancé
que ont parlé des chiffres en fait c'est
moins de 1 25 % la population qui
chassent donc quid aussi dans ce
phénomène de sécurité de la majorité de
la population enfin qui du coup soit se
sent en danger ou pas mais c'est quand
même
98 5 % de la population et donc nous
c'est pour ça que ce que disait ma
collègue aussi c'est un peu la réflexion
autour de la règle et de l'exception est
ce qu'on dit que la règle c'est la
chasse et du coup après tout le monde
s'adapte ou alors l'exception c'est la
chasse est encore une fois comme ça se
passe en allemagne en angleterre en
suisse etc on dit que dans certains
endroits effectivement y'a trop de
renard ya trop de sangliers il ya trop
de certaines espèces et du coup il faut
qu'on y réguler un petit peu et pourquoi
considérer que partout ce serait le même
la même
même critique envers telle ou oui merci
je tiens à préciser que parmi les oraux
en colère nous avons également la
fédération equiliberté nous avons
beaucoup de cavaliers en fait la
fédération nationale et qui liberté qui
représente les cavaliers randonneurs et
certains professionnels aussi et nous
avons des professionnels du tourisme
équestre un bon nombre et que à titre
personnel je dirige une agence de voyage
à cheval qui fait voyager quatre mille
cavaliers chaque année en france et à
l'étranger donc la question de
l'équitation d'extérieur est quelque
chose que nous connaissons assez bien et
est effectivement énormément de
cavaliers donc renonce complètement à se
promener en saison de chasse et la
saison de chasse comme suit le rappelait
tout à l'heure maintenant c'est plus
septembre février ça commence au 1er
juin et ça finit au 31 mars il ne reste
plus que deux mois avril et m dans la
plupart des départements en tout cas par
exemple chez moi en isère vous parliez
de charte et de la nécessité de
connaître les lieux de chasse et il y a
une une
expérimentation qui a lieu en isère
depuis deux ans avec une application qui
s'appelle landsheere
et dont apparemment les fédérations
attendent beaucoup de bien je peux vous
dire que moi je la pratique depuis deux
ans cette application elle m'a été
absolument totalement inutile au
contraire elle m'a mise en insécurité
puisque toutes les batteries ne sont pas
déclarés et donc alors je peux vous dire
j'ai pris des copies d'écran donc chez
moi dans ma maison ma maison le samedi
battu dimanche battue samedi d'après
battu dimanche d'après battu tout ça
pendant un mois après confinement ouais
on peut se peut sortir dans à km autour
alors s'est fait plaisir on a sorti à km
autour c'était mieux déjà que les
week-ends allemand le week-end d'après
les chasseurs réautoriser bon où on
était toujours confiné le week end
encore après
samedi battu dimanche battue encore
après samedi battu dimanche pas de
battues signalé sur l'enchère via ma
fille on va sortir prends ton chauffage
prends mon vtt on sort on va mettre
toutes les chances de notre côté puisque
landsheere ne signale pas les chasseurs
individuelle et autres peuvent être
absolument n'importe où n'importe quand
puisque la chasse est autorisée 7 jours
sur 7 sauf en isère on a de la chance
c'est le vendredi le jour sans chasse ça
sert absolument à rien
ah ben non c'est ou alors il faudrait
bête que le mercredi le repos